البعض مشاهدينا بيتساهل في شراء المضادات
الحيويه وبدون وصفه طبيه اعتقادا منهم
انها الطريقه الاسرع للتخلص من اي مرض لكن
هذا الامر له مخاطر طبيه عديده جدا
فانتبهوا اكيد نصيحه جديده وقويه تاتي هذه
المره من منظمه الصحه العالميه اللي طالبت
الدول بترشيد استخدام المضادات الحيويه
وان يتم استهلاكها بشكل
عقلاني طبعا بحسب المنظمه بعض انواع
العدوى الفيروسيه لا تتطلب تناول مضادات
حيويه كما انه موضوع اكمال دوره المضاد
الحيوي بناء على تعليمات الطبيب هي من
الامور الهامه جدا
وقلما يتم ذلك اصلا والناس بتخلص الكورس
المنظمه نصحت عدم مشاركه اي شخص المضاد
الحيوي الخاص به مع العائله او الاصدقاء
لان لكل فرد حاله واعراض محدده يعاني منها
[موسيقى]
مشكله انه احنا نستسهل هذا الامر بينما في
الدول الغربيه ما تاخذينها الا بواسطه
اليوم اه تعبانه
مضاد حيوي مثلا حاولت الدول العربيه حاولت
تنظم هذا الموضوع وانه تطلب لازم وصفه
طبيه ولكن مع ذلك الناس عمالها كتير
بتستسهل هذا الموضوع وزي ما ذكرنا اهم اشي
انه ممكن يكون الالتهاب فيروسي وعلى
الفاضي انت بتاخد المضاد طبعا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات